good morning it's seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast it's all about
cover-ups this morning the first part of
the government's covet plan b
to limit the spread of omicron comes
into force in england today including
the mandatory wearing of face masks in
more indoor venues meanwhile boris
johnson's under increasing pressure from
his own mps andry at the new
restrictions and of course the ongoing
rally over christmas party claims and
the refurbishment of his number 10 flats
also ahead
heading off on a new mission we'll be
speaking to the british astronauts tim
peake about inspiring school children to
do their science homework
this is samantha
i think she was about 10 months old
and it's a delightful picture and it's
black and white and i love black and
white
and we'll hear from the journalists
traveling the country to record people's
lifestyles after losing his own father
during the pandemic
it's friday the 10th of december
facing up to plan b in the fight against
clovid masters now have to be worn in
more indoor settings in england
it is a drinking venue as well and it's
very hard to police especially during
the show
in darkness without
interrupting the customer but also the
show itself
hospitality industry says customers will
be put up as the government signed his
describes and restrictions as a
necessary evil
pm under pressure the tory backbench
rebellion against boris johnson's plan b
as he faces a series of allegations
quarantined quarrel the traveler is
furious at the cost and condition at the
state of hotel accommodation
we are treated like prisoners like
animals
you the the number of gods is
disproportionate to the risk
guilty the actor justice smallest is
convicted of staging a racist homophobic
attack on himself in what prosecutors
say was a bid to bolster his career
i thought the evidence was overwhelming
that in fact mr smallett had faked a
hate crime and then lied to the police
about it
unaware of the tragedy rapper travis
scott says he had no idea that 10 people
had been killed in a crush at his music
festival in texas
even after the show you know you're just
kind of hearing hearing things
but you don't know i didn't know the
exact details until
you know minutes before the press
conference
the weather cold and windy with a mix of
sunshine and showers
[Music]
hello good morning face masks must be
worn in more settings including cinemas
theaters and churches as measures are
tightened in england it's in a bid to
slow the spread of the omicron variants
it's the first stage of the government's
move to so-called plan b covert
restrictions
well under today's changes face masks
will be required in more public settings
including theaters and cinemas
masks will not be needed in pubs or
restaurants
from monday people will be asked to work
from home where possible
from wednesday the nhs covered pass will
also be required for visitors to
nightclubs indoor unseated venues with
more than 500 people
unseated outdoor venues with more than 4
000 people and any event with more than
ten thousand people
officials in scotland have gone further
though public health scotland is calling
for all christmas parties to be
cancelled
sky's melina viscelinovic reports
these theater goers were among the last
to enjoy a performance unmasked in
england
face coverings are now compulsory in
most indoor venues but those who run
them say enforcing the rules will be a
challenge
it is a drinking venue as well and it's
very hard to police especially during a
show
in darkness without
interrupting the customer but also the
show itself people who are coming out
want to have a good time and trying to
tell a group of people that potentially
had a few drinks during the day
that they have to wear their mask is
definitely a flash point on the doors
news of restrictions has already hit
business in this theater
all right okay so we're about twenty
percent down on what we were supposed
about and while mosques won't be needed
in pubs or restaurants advice to work
from home could cut their income too
well it's still really busy here but the
fear is that once the work from home
mandate kicks in fewer people will be
inclined to go out for spontaneous
drinks or dinner hurting the hospitality
industry just as it was starting to
recover
reduced footfall is bad news for those
catering to office workers telling
people to stay at home is going to have
a massive impact on city centre
businesses many of whom have suffered a
torrid 18 months are only just getting
back on their feet right now so really
concerning to see
from wednesday these fans will have to
show vaccine passports or a negative
lateral flow test for a big match like
this one
on that opinions are divided
i'm double vaxxed so i'm happy too
not a problem for you nope not a problem
for me how about yourself i am double
back so i've got a vaccine passport so
i'm okay i'm not entirely sure i'm
comfortable with it it's a breach of
human rights you should be able to
decide whether or not you get vaccinated
we've given our money to west ham united
so they've got our money already
so you're now saying that my son can't
enjoy football
just because he hasn't been vaccinated
restrictions are never good for business
but the government hopes they will curb
omicron enough to avoid more stringent
measures in the future
milena vaseline sky news
well charlotte lomas is in central
london for us now charlotte good morning
to you what's the reaction then from
business this morning
good morning uh vanessa well yes we're
here in trafalgar square in center of
london just in front of martin the
fields church we've obviously got the
national gallery within walking distance
and and surrounded by theaters and it
has to be inside all of these places as
of today you'll have to wear a face mask
if you go inside them and it's already
obviously been a mandate and legal
requirement since no end of november to
wear a face mask in shops and on public
transport and now in the majority
of indoor settings if you want to visit
them you'll have to wear a face mask and
really as you were hearing in the report
lots of businesses are concerned about
the tightening of restrictions but many
people that i've been talking to over
the last couple of days have said this
really is necessary and then the right
thing to do in order to try and stop the
rapid spread of omicron as yes as of
yesterday there was
817 confirmed cases and there has been
warnings from the health secretary this
could rise to 1 million cases by the end
of this month so the government really
want to try and slow down that spread
and allow more time for people to get
vaccinated to get their booster jab and
to really try and get the most at the
highest level of protection available to
try and
slow down and stop the impact of omicron
charlotte thank you
and just some breaking news for you this
morning the latest gdp figures have just
been released the show output grew by
just
0.1
in october it remains 0.5
below pre-pandemic levels
well syrian theorem head of economics at
the british chambers of commerce joins
me now thanks for your time this morning
here on sky news you've seen the figures
were there what you were expecting
and they're probably a bit weaker um
than we expected and what was quite
interesting about dating this data for
october so it hasn't really got the
impact of a new variant in the data and
what we've seen is the actual down
pressure on activity in the month was
actually driven by other headwinds
particularly supply chain disruption
which impacted output in manufacturing
and construction sectors
looking at what's coming into force
today with plan b how concerned are you
and your members about the working from
home um restrictions that's coming into
place and also as we approach the
festive
period too
yeah certainly while these new measures
are less restricted than what we've seen
previous the our concern is what the
impact these new measures will have on
consumer behavior now we've already seen
over recent weeks because of the new
variant
less people going to restaurants uh
christmas parties being cancelled and
the concern is with these new measures
such as working from home is that the
retail footfall in in key areas in
retail hospitality particularly in city
centers is going to fall and that's of
course and this is doing it a real key
period for those sectors because the
christmas period is where they make a
lot of their revenue for the head of the
quarter months in the next couple of
months
so with that being said that i'd like to
get your views then do you support the
tightening of restrictions because
governments obviously moving to plan b
many tory mps are against this move
planning to vote against it next week
well what we'd like to see is
the restrictions are one thing but what
we'd like to see alongside those is
actually support for those businesses
that will be impacted by those
restrictions so more support for re for
retail hospitality this could include
for example reinstating the five percent
vat rate for these businesses to help
them through what's going to be
difficult trading period over the next
couple of months
so as we approach christmas then we have
had the issue with supply chain problems
we saw a few weeks ago as we approach um
christmas can you just give us an update
on a supply chain disruption that's
still facing the uk
we are still hearing quite significant
issues around supply chain disruption
and this is very much broad base across
the economy and we're hearing issues
again with driver shortages which is
impacting and getting goods into on
shelves and into factories so that's
clearly having an impact and what we're
also seeing is the impact of staff
shortages as well so there's a number of
headwinds facing uk economies supply
chain disruption there's staff shortages
and of course there's new variants as
well since so it's gonna be difficult a
few months for the uk economy
and the scottish government has strongly
urged people to defer christmas parties
what does this messaging do to business
july because throughout this pandemic
aside from right at the beginning we've
had so many conflicting messages haven't
we between the nations what impact is
this having on business
well a lot of this sort of mixed message
messaging has
created greater uncertainty not only
what happens now but also what happens
in the future but what's also saying for
all the businesses is that they've had
little time to adapt to the new changes
this has been a constant theme through
the pandemic so that's created more
costs and more concern for a lot of
businesses across the uk particularly a
critical trading period for those in
retail and hospitality
and also your outlook on gdp growth was
published before plan b of course but
was already projected to slow down more
than expected so how will you revise it
now
it's like to be rise uh further downward
we did have quite a good a significant
impact from the new variant but it's
like we've rising a bit smaller over
their periods um because one of the key
drivers of the uk economy is consumer
spending that's critical at this time of
year given the run-up to christmas and
what we likely see is consumers become
more reluctant to socialize and spend
and that's going to have a impact on the
wider uk economy
syrian thorough thanks for your time
still to come on the show as the
government wins the latest legal
challenge against covet quarantine
restrictions we'll be speaking to the
legal team trying to overturn the
current rules
as tougher restrictions for theater
audiences come into force we'll speak to
the boss of the west end's biggest
venues
for the lockdown measures taken up so
far stop the spread of omicron we'll
talk to a leading epidemiologist just
after eight o'clock
[Music]
now there's still intense pressure on
the prime minister this morning as he
faces a number of tricky questions is
understood that mr johnson's most senior
communications advisor gave a speech to
staff and handed out awards on the nice
of the alleged downing street party last
year
jack doyle oversees the communications
strategy which has seen number 10 deny
that any party has taken place
or the investigation into claims of
illegal gatherings in westminster last
christmas has been widened the cabinet
office will look at claims that the
leaving party was held in downing street
on november the 27th 2020. it's alleged
mr johnson himself gave a speech as an
informal drinks evening
the second to be looked at will be a
party at the department of education
officials have admitted there was an
event for staff on december 10 last year
and the investigation will also look
into claims of a christmas party in
number 10 on the 18th of december last
year it's reported there was food drinks
and games at the gathering which lasted
until after midnight
meanwhile labour has accused mr johnson
of lying to his standards advisor over
the refurbishment of his downing street
flat
angela rayner says the prime minister
misled lord gates by saying he did not
know who was behind the funding of the
work
the prime minister's problems dominate
this morning's front pages
let's start with the daily telegraph
then it understands that the prime
minister's advisor on standards may
resign over allegations he was misled
about who paid for refurbishments to
boris and carrie johnson's flat
the story is also on the front page of
the guardian which says mr johnson is
accused of misleading the watchdog
the metro newspaper suggests that the
birth of the johnson's new baby takes a
prime minister out of the firing line
for now
but the eye indicates that the reprieve
may not last long though with rishi
sunup and liz trust said to be
considering leadership challenges
against mr johnson
the daily mail says that the prime
minister could face a backbench revolt
it claims up to 50 conservative mps
could vote against new restrictions
any times reports that a conservative
party have slumped to their worst poll
ratings in 11 months as the prime
minister battles on several fronts
let's take a look then at the latest
daily covert data and there have been 50
867 new cases of covert 19 recorded in
the latest 24 hour period
another 148 deaths have been reported
within 28 days of a positive test so
that brings a total number of deaths in
the uk to 146
135
to the vaccine rollouts now and 21 700
people received their first dose of a
vaccine
while 29
437 people received their second so what
this means is that the total number of
people who have received their second
dose is over
46.6 million
and 414
645 booster and third jabs were given in
the latest 24-hour period taking the
total number of those doses to more than
21.7 million
another news any actor justice mollets
has been convicted of staging a hate
crime against himself
prosecutors in chicago say that it was
part of an attempt to gain sympathy and
bolster his career
our u.s correspondent greg milan reports
this was jesse smallett with a noose
around his neck on the night he says he
suffered a racist and homophobic attack
nearly three years later he arrived at
court to hear a jury decide that the
attack was a hoax staged by smallett
himself mr smaller what's your hope for
the verdict here guilty of making false
reports to police
he could face three years in prison
brothers abimbola and olobinjo osandero
told the trial they were recruited by
smilet and paid to buy supplies for the
attack
they said he wanted them to rough him up
and shout slurs which made them appear
to be supporters of then president
donald trump all in front of security
cameras the prosecutor accused smilet of
harming the cause of the real victims of
hate crimes i told the jury
that i thought the evidence was
overwhelming
that in fact mr smallett had faked a
hate crime
and then lied to the police about it
and then compounded his crimes
by lying to the jury
during the course of this trial and
insulting their intelligence
throughout the trial smilet had
continued to claim that there was no
hoax and that he was the real victim
we remain 100 percent confidence in our
client's innocence
from the first day of this case his case
has been pre-judged his case has been
tried in the media
and it's unfortunate this is the united
states of america we live in a
constitutional democracy where everyone
is presumed innocent
but obviously if we're being honest that
hasn't been the case
when the hoax was discovered police said
smilet had used the pain and anger of
racism to further his career
ultimately he lost his role in the show
empire and told jurors he'd lost his
livelihood as well
when he's sentenced in the new year he
could also lose his liberty greg milam
sky news los angeles
now also making the news this morning
american rap star travis scott says he
was unaware that people had died at his
music festival in texas until after
he performed
ten people were killed during a stampede
at the event in houston last month in
his first interview since the accidents
the rapper told sharmilan the gods
youtube channel that he had been an
emotional roller coaster
even after the show you know you're just
kind of hearing hearing things
um but you don't know i didn't know the
exact details until
you know minutes before the press
conference
and even at that moment you kind of just
like wait you know what the thing is
like you know people pass out you know
people you know things happen at
concerts
but something like that
it's just like
at least 54 people have been killed and
another 105 injured after a lorry packed
with people crashed into a pedestrian
bridge in southern mexico
officials say the victims appeared to be
migrants from central america though
their nationalities have yet to be
confirmed
local authorities said that those
responsible for the accidents and
migrant trafficking will be held to
account
a royal navy serviceman has been found
dead at the naval base which is home to
the uk's nuclear submarine fleet
police say the death that the high
security site in argyll and boots is so
far unexplained
now he's probably had a sleepless night
after the arrival of his new daughter
but there is plenty of other problems
for boris johnson to be worrying about
certainly to keep him awake isn't it as
well as claims of illegal parties and
downing street there's the allegation
that he misled an investigation into the
refurbishment of his flat at 10 downing
street
plus he's facing a growing rebellion
from his own backbenchers over those new
covert restrictions well joining me now
is tom peck parliamentary sketch writer
and columnist at the independence tom
what a week for prime minister
yeah i mean it's epic really isn't it i
mean
one forgets he began this week standing
in the dark before dawn dressed up as
the police officer to launch crime week
and within a few hours
um effectively his entire staff are
accused of committing a crime within his
own house which he denies happened
there's also we almost forget the fact
that he is a foreign office
whistleblower suggests that capacity was
used to evacuate dogs before people from
afghanistan his advisor has only been in
the job for a year because after the
last one quit over the british patel
bullying allegations looks like he's
gonna quit because effectively he
believes he's been lied to
um it doesn't really end does it he's
had a lot of terrible terrible terrible
weeks but
not quite as terrible as this one
baby notwithstanding
absolutely and even with the arrival of
the baby as some of the papers are
suggesting you know he will get a bit of
a reprieve but only for now because this
story will continue wouldn't it
obviously what we're discussing in terms
of the partying christmas parties flat
refurbishment you know the revolt next
week that he's looking ahead to so next
week is going to be an interesting week
for him isn't he or we've also got of
course the um elections that's coming up
following the resignation of owen
patterson so
more to come next week prime minister
yeah as you said a by-election next week
and a by-election caused effectively by
his own attempt to
see off the um the uh standards
commissioner largely to prevent her
doing an investigation into him and he
handled that so badly that he now has a
by-election which he's probably going to
lose um he's one of his senior advisers
as you will know allegra stratton
resigned um
yesterday or the day before um and
that's really a problem because she
effectively resigned because she made a
joke about a party that she quite
probably wasn't at now she's resigned
because she made a joke about it there
were 50 people also who are actually at
it including it now seems his own
director of communications jack doyle
he's been spending the last week telling
all of his team to deny the existence of
a party
that he almost certainly attended so how
many of those guys are going to have to
resign when that when they're when one
of them was resigned for joking about
the thing that they actually did i
wouldn't like to be in their shoes
either so there is plenty more
um gunpowder to go off if you like and i
can't see how it isn't going to go off
either
there were many sacrificial lambs in
this wouldn't there and i'm interesting
to pick up on what you just said you
think that he's going to lose that by
election then do you because boris
johnson has been holding his own for
quite some time despite any allegations
of sleaze that has followed him in the
last months
well one makes predictions in
by-elections um
at grave risk these days um the only
thing that tends to happen is the most
unlikely event tends to be the one that
does happen
and i think if the lib dems
when they pulled off that remarkable
will in cheshire and amisham and i know
that privately they're quite confident
in north shropshire and the
conservatives are pretty terrified the
extent that some of them are privately
conceding that it's already lost
when it gets to that stage it probably
is lost but you know we've all been
wrong before
and of course we had old bexley and sid
cup didn't we as well and they managed
to um take that as well let's just talk
about the met police their decision not
to investigate is it a case that they're
saying that there isn't any evidence is
it a case that they're just probably not
looking hard enough because this is one
of the most you know monitored buildings
i imagine you know number 10.
police are standing outside for crying
out loud you know there must be endless
cctv
well they have a policy in existence
which is not to retrospectively
investigate previous um kobe breaches
and that
that is a real policy and then
arguably in their view it would be
unfair to break it purely for
for because this is a high profile case
but then at the same time you know john
paul schultz was dressed up as a police
officer on monday he knows very well
that the way this country works the way
the police office police service works
in these countries policing by consent
there are more market forces at play i
don't really think there is anybody in
the country who wouldn't think that this
case is high profile enough important
enough
and the police's own reputation at stake
enough to potentially look again at
whether this rule should necessarily
apply to it it's extremely serious and
to a certain extent why is it at stake
is all of the people the entire
population's willingness to comply with
new regulations that have been brought
in this week to a certain extent rest on
whether or not this breach was taken
seriously so arguably the police should
think again about whether or not that
rule should apply in this very very very
excuse me very very important case
tom thanks for your time this morning
as a pleasure thank you thank you
well let's check in on the weather now
shall we
change against the government's latest
quarantine restrictions now campaigners
try to overturn the requirement for
travelers from 11 countries to spend 10
days in an official hotel regardless of
their vaccination status
they say conditions in the hotels
amounts to
are too expensive and amount to a breach
of human rights
now people forced to stay in quarantine
hotels have told sky news that they're
being held in terrible conditions and
treated like prisoners
a high court judge has blocked a legal
challenge to the government's hotel
quarantine system for people returning
from redless destinations but some of
those we spoke to said that there was no
choice of food and that they were banned
from using their phones sky studio
children has this report
this is not a prison yard
it's the car park of a quarantine hotel
the video was shot by sven jose who is
staying here after returning from south
africa this month
it's extremely stressful
we are treated like prisoners like
animals
you the the number of gods is
disproportionate to the risk that is
actually here
over 200 000 people like sven have had
to quarantine in hotels upon traveling
to the uk from countries on the red list
it costs more than 2 000 pounds each and
comes with some strict rules
we are allowed to speak to the media
but we are not allowed to take any
photographs we're not allowed to film
today i was aggressively told to put my
telephone away to not film not take
photographs when the fire alarm was set
off at ella's hotel she said chaos
ensued she and her toddler are at a
hotel near gatwick airport she says
quarantining at home in wilmslow would
have been much easier for her
two-year-old son we need to be going
outside with him we're allowed 20
minutes outside a day if we're lucky
secondly the food choices there is no
choice for children it is only
what they get delivered and that's it
there's no option of what to give them
if it wasn't for my sister living nearby
um she lives about an hour away and
dropping me up some food for him he
would go hungry now lawyers representing
a thousand travelers said they would
appeal a judicial review decision on the
matter they argue that mandatory hotel
quarantine for fully vaccinated people
is unlawful and an interference with the
right to personal liberty we're willing
to take it as far as we need to go so um
if we're unsuccessful at the court of
appeal then we'll go to the european
court of human rights in strasbourg this
is something that i'm very passionate
about and and it has impacted as i say
so many people we're going to continue
fighting it in a statement the
government told sky news we have taken
precautionary and temporary action at
the border to help slow down the seeding
of the omicron variant in the uk from
abroad buying time for our scientists to
learn more about the variant
a petition for people to self-isolate at
home has had more than a hundred
thousand signatures and is due to be
debated in parliament in january
sadia chowdhury sky news in cheshire
well joining me live now is tom goodhead
you saw it you saw in that piece whose
company lost that legal challenge
against hotel quarantine yesterday
and also joined by
another um guest but actually we'll be
speaking to some a few other people too
um tom but first let's just um stay with
you as we were just saying that you've
lost that legal um challenge that
judicial review will you be
appealing
we are yes we're appealing in the next
seven days we were extremely
disappointed with um the judgment
yesterday we're grateful obviously to
the um judge for considering and the
arguments that we made on behalf of our
clients but i was extremely disappointed
by the outcome and i think it it's the
wrong decision
just remind us what was the basis of
your um argument in the first place
yeah so the the legal challenge is that
this breach is article 5 of the european
convention of human rights which is the
right to liberty so the right to your
your personal freedoms not to be um
detained um by the states you've heard
many of the people that we represent and
people that just featured on your
program now have described these
conditions as being prison-like and i
think the best way um to put it um is
that i mean it's a slightly more
luxurious version of a prison it's
perhaps maybe what people perceive um
prison to be like um for uh if you
believe that people are soft on crime
but the reality is is that the state
takes control of nearly every single um
facet of your everyday life whilst
you're in detention i mean that is
prison there's no other way to describe
it
now has it come as a surprise to you
that the prime minister has admitted
that you have a very fair challenge
it's ridiculous isn't it i mean
yesterday the government had um two
lawyers in court um saying that this was
unarguable yet on wednesday evening um
the prime minister describes it as a
very fair challenge that probably tells
you um all you need to know about the
state of the government's thinking at
the moment in relation and to this issue
well that really shows you you know just
how conflicting many things are isn't it
during this um pandemic especially we
hear one thing from the government and
one thing from others now is there a
good chance then that you know this
results could
end in quarantine hotels
i mean i i get the feeling that
politically and it's starting to come
towards an end now anyway i think the
the public mood has changed very sadly a
lot of this is about politics i don't
believe that the policy was ever really
grounded um in science i think it was a
perception of not having acted um hard
enough during and bringing travel
restrictions in at the beginning of the
first lockdown or when the pandemic
started and then a need to try and show
that the uk was being tougher than
pretty much any other um government in
europe and in fact now worldwide even
australia is no longer um pursuing this
this policy
sadly as with many things with his
governments i think it's politics rather
than anything informed by by science or
informed by law
tom goodhead thanks for your time this
morning
thank
you
well let's speak now to emily manny and
owen hancock who are currently in a
hotel quarantine having arrived back
from south africa good morning to you
both just tell us about your experiences
so far
well our experience has been very
frustrating and very challenging we were
away visiting emily's family who we
haven't seen in two and a half years
because we were waiting for south africa
to go on the green list when we were
there the rug was pulled from underneath
us saying if we want to come home we
have to do this enforced imprisonment
and that has to come at a cost of nearly
4 000 pounds for us and it's um it's
been equally frustrating once we've
arrived back in the uk
and some people have talked about the
conditions there in terms of the food
and the treatment
how have you been finding it
we think it's just really frustrating
like if we were able to quarantine at
home we could you know eat what we want
to eat we'd be able to kind of you know
make our own food we haven't actually
been able to go out for any exercise and
we've requested it but just no one has
come to our door so
i think we really are backing pgmbm's um
appeal in the court and we just think it
is totally unfair unreasonable and
unacceptable that we are double
vaccinated traveled when we were allowed
to travel followed all the rules and
clearly the prime minister and his
number 10 downing street staff do not
follow the same rules that we are
supposed to
and that's exactly actually i was going
to touch on that so obviously we're
hearing the revelations of potential
parties legal parties that took place
and then we have the likes of you who
are following the rules so
how does that make you feel that the
rule the rule makers are also the rule
breakers
potentially
it's absolutely disgusting and i think
it shows just how ill thought through
some of the policies are from this
government we um when hotel pointing was
imposed they cancelled all the flights
back to the uk from south africa so we
then had to go later when we booked on
our flight the hotel quarantine wasn't
available to us so
we had to move our flights again and
it's just it makes your blood boil
doesn't it to know that you're doing all
of this trying to be so diligent with
your travel plans to see your family
members and then the government itself
can't even be bothered to stick to their
owns i'd also just like to add on to
that we've started a petition on
change.org and we've got about 60 000
signatures in just over a week so there
are so many people that are in exactly
the same situation as us and we're just
trying you know to help everyone kind of
get out of this
imprisonment that we have to pay you
know so much money for
emily thank you emily um manny and owen
hancock thanks for your time
well time now to take a look at what's
happening in the world of sport now and
jackie is here for us jackie what's
happening
wow calm down johnny it's only a game
brought to you by vitality sharing the
benefits of healthy
living good morning well what's
happening vanessa is england captain joe
roots and darwin milan have led the
fight back on day three of the first
ash's test against australia at the gaba
having been tasked with wiping out a
278-run deficit they now trail by just
58 runs at stumps resuming on 343-7
australia continued to build a
commanding lead travis head brought up
150 from just 143 balls after hitting
the third fastest century in ash's
history
australia added 82 this morning to grow
their lead from 196 to 278
as they were eventually all out for a
massive 425.
now in reply england's second innings
was not off to a great start rory burns
managed to avoid another duck but was
out for just 13 here caught behind by
alex kerry
the wicket of his opening partner haseeb
hamid followed soon after he fell for 27
also caught behind by kerry
but captain root and milan have given
england hope with a solid partnership
and some superb batting
roots putting his first innings duck
behind him to pass 50 from 80 balls for
his 51st test half century he now holds
the record for the most test runs in a
calendar year by an englishman
he's also just two runs short of his
highest test score in australia on 86
not out milan there as well both look to
be closing in on centuries they've put
on a partnership 159 runs and england
closed the day 224
2.
now busy nights in the europa league
with mixed fortunes for the british
sides in action last night
disappointment for leicester they drop
into the europa conference league after
a 3-2 defeat to napoli
west ham had already booked their place
in the knockout stages at the top of
group h they have
had opportunities rather
for their youngsters in their final game
against dinamo zagreb but it was the
croatian side who came out on top a
one-nil win means they finished second
in the group behind the hammers
rangers finished second in group a after
a one or draw in lyon giovanni van
bronco's side will take on one of the
eight teams to drop out of the champions
league
celtic boss and poster cochlear says
there are plenty of positives this i can
take despite not making it through to
the knockout stages celtic finished with
a win it was 3-2 at home to rail betis
last night but they drop into the europa
conference league
now there is no doubt about the big
event this weekend the climax of this
year's formula one championship in abu
dhabi it all comes down to the last race
with lewis hamilton and matt's
verstappen level on points with one race
to go hamilton has played down
suggestions verstappen could take him
out of the race in order to claim the
championship hamilton collided with the
back of the stafford's car in last
weekend's saudi arabian grand prix and
it all adds to what should be a
thrilling
finale
and coverage of practice one gets
underway from 9 30 this morning live on
sky sports f1 i'm back in announce time
see them
handball
handball
handball ref handball
jackie thank you coming up on sky news
breakfast as tougher restrictions for
theater audiences coming to force we'll
be speaking to the boss of the west
end's biggest venues
[Music]
i put a smell on you
[Music]
say hello to the world's true champion
an enduring hero a winner
the epson eco tank big bottles less
hassle loads of ink enough for all of
this say goodbye to ink cartridges with
epson eco tank just fill in chill
on a great hair day i feel that little
bit stronger
my hair won't bring home the title but
feeling unbreakable sure can
because the power of hair isn't just how
it looks is how it makes you feel
pantene grows strong with biotin and
bamboo for stronger longer hair awaken
your hair and your power
try pantene lift and volume with biotin
and rose water get fuller thicker
looking hair pantene
oh i see you installed an alarm yes a
very sure alarm it's getting dark so
early these days how do you like it
amazing peace of mind we activate it
every night and when we're out excellent
we should get an alarm there ashore
alarms and cameras install your alarm
now get a free arlo video doorbell call
now or start your quote at veryshore.com
mark's christmas will be spent on a
pavement
john can't remember when he wasn't on
the streets
tessie feels safer here than at home
please help the salvation army bring a
homeless person in from the cold by
calling 800 0048
your 19 pounds will help show them
someone cares and give them the chance
of a fresh start this christmas
thank you
it's their special story
when they're in the book
their picture inside the cover
look i'm in the book a story with their
name bedtime will never be the same look
it's me
adventures with their favorites or
finding something new in the book is
where their greatest dreams come true
get 10 off all our children's books this
christmas
at inthebook.com
i've been exploring to find bingo
inspiration for me foxy fabulous me cup
of tea
[Music]
grab a free prize with me snow globe
game every day
oh
discover the fun at foxy bingo
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
friday will start cold and showery with
a patchy frost but eastern britain will
be mainly dry island northern ireland
and western britain will see showers
through the morning some heavy with hail
and thunder and hill snow possible much
of eastern scotland and eastern england
will stay dry and sunny it'll be cold
and windy for all
the afternoon will be similar but the
showers will ease going into the evening
low air pollution levels are expected
again measuring just two or three on the
daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now sex in the city became famous for
both shocking and delighting viewing
with explicit depictions of the lives
and sex lives of professional women and
it's been reborn on sky
now in their 50s carrie miranda and
charlotte are back in manhattan now
there's no samantha but despite growing
older the sex is still there our arts
and entertainment correspondent katie
spencer reports
[Music]
when sex in the city came out in 1998
collective jaws dropped at its frankness
before then sex on tv tended to be from
a male gaze and was well a bit
unrealistic this was four single women
openly talking about either wanting it
or having it
now two decades later they're at it
again
if you have good friends in your corner
anything's possible
to get fans in the mood in london
tickets to see a pop-up recreation of
carrie's apartment sold out in 24 hours
the thing about sets in the city is that
at the time it felt incredibly
emancipating and it really was but if
you watch some of those episodes again
there are some questionable issues the
very affluent almost entirely white
circles that they move in the gay
stereotypes not to mention the
occasionally questionable views on
sexual
consent starring in a one-woman show off
broadway real-life carrie bradshaw
candice bushnell whose book the series
was based on says its message wasn't
very feminist in the end
that time
was a very unfeminist time if you
remember there were so many actresses
who were saying i'm not a feminist
so
when
money is free-flowing there's less
feminism
when money's tighter and women have to
work and can't rely on men so much
there's feminism
as well as a new name the new series has
been given awoke makeover with racially
diverse friends even a non-binary
character
i think that's why it's so important
they kind of tread lightly and um to
make sure that the storyline kind of
covers you know current times and also
is relatable as well because um not just
the old friends will be watching will be
introduced to a new range of audiences
the future is unwritten because we're
all at different stages of life
so what can we expect from this next
chapter well while sets in the city was
revolutionary in terms of how young
sexually active women were depicted on
tv don't rule out the reboots doing the
same for another group that's rarely
represented on screen women in their 50s
hello lovers
so hold on to your cosmos casey spencer
sky news
now from tonight theater and cinema
audiences in england will have to mask
up when the curtain comes down
but as pantos take on the stage how will
the theaters cope with restrictions
well joining me now dame rosemary squire
who's joint chief executive of trafalgar
entertainment thanks for your time this
morning as we're just saying they're all
chained for your customers from tonight
how do you feel about having to re
enforce the mask wearing rooms
well we have been asking our customers
to wear their masks all of our staff
since we reopened fully in july to make
our theaters as safe as possible all our
staff have been wearing masks you know
front of house behind the bars and we
have been requesting our customers to
wear them but not enforcing it now we're
going to actually it's a clearer message
they're required to wear masks now
obviously not when eating or drinking
and obviously kids are exempt so it's a
sensible move i think one that the
industry supports
and how do you think customers are going
to take that
i think we're all used to it you know i
think we're now if you live in london or
one of the major cities we're all used
to wearing masks on public transport or
on the tube or on buses um and in shops
you know it's a part of life i'm here in
sydney actually opening our new theater
theatre in sydney with jagged little
pill fantastic new musical our audiences
here are in masks and masks are really
more prevalently worn here in sydney
than they are in the uk pretty well
everywhere apart from outdoors so you
know we get on with it people want to
come to the theater theatre is open we
have great shows for people to see for
families to come and enjoy this
christmas you know pantomime is just as
much a part of christmas as the crackers
or the turkey
how concerned are you about further
measures what would another lockdown do
to the industry
oh another lockdown would be devastating
you know our industry um
the usp is that we are live we can't
function at all unless uh we are live in
the moment and you know it was
extraordinary the moments when we opened
reopened fully in july i was in the
theater at the barbican watching out
anything goes preview of it and the
audience were in tears the cast were in
tears that it meant so much after 18
months of not being able to do their
jobs that there they were with a live
audience in the moment telling their
stories it was a wonderful experience
and it's one that you know we've grown
up with it's part of what makes us human
we love telling listening to stories
sharing that experience and we can't do
it unless it's live so i think all the
mental health benefits all the economic
benefits creative industries are huge
employers bring billions to our economy
and it would be devastating to be locked
down again but that's not going to
happen we're taking sensible measures
we are
wearing our masks and we're all having a
great time in theater
and those measures that you're taking
how then does it affect your performance
and also the audiences
well performers we've um since we've
come back we've been unbelievably
careful with testing daily keeping
people in covid safe bubbles rehearsing
shows in bubbles yes there are some
cases and you know um we've had a few
shows have had to lose performances my
company we've lost a few performances
because several has been an outbreak in
a company but mostly not
mostly we've been performing as normal
it's the exception a few rare cases that
we've lost to show here and there and i
think it's we're used to doing it we're
very disciplined about it and we're
carrying on so that people can come and
enjoy live entertainment and see it
safely
you're remaining optimistic there dame
rosemary squire thank you
thank you
so what about the weather well let's
check in
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well today looks cold with a mix of
sunshine and blustery showers so do grab
your brolly but the weekend will be
milder and more unsettled now for now
there are showers around some heavy and
wintry but much of eastern britain is
dry and there's just some lingering
patchy rain over east anglia it's cold
but mostly frost free now the rain over
norfolk and suffolk will clear during
the morning leaving eastern england and
eastern scotland largely dry and sunny
elsewhere there will be a mixture of
sunshine and blustery showers some heavy
with hail thunder and hill snow possible
and it will feel cold especially in the
brisk wind